well the United States is concerned that
North Korea is planning to sell weapons
to Russia including artillery ammunition
neither the Russians nor the North
Koreans are confirming media reports
that Kim Jong-un is planning to meet
Vladimir Putin this month Russia's
defense minister says plans for joint
military exercises with North Korea have
been discussed Hadi Jo Castro has more
now for us from Washington D.C
the meeting between Kim Jong-un and
Vladimir Putin may occur this month with
the North Korean leader traveling by
armored train to the Russian coastal
city of larivostok and potentially from
there on to Moscow the White House said
last week that high-level talks between
Russia and North Korea were actively
advancing with poon and Kim exchanging
letters about a possible arms deal the
U.S says that last year North Korea
delivered to Russia infantry rockets and
missiles and Russia has been asking for
more since Russia's defense minister
traveled to Pyongyang last month to meet
with Kim and then a North Korean
delegation visited Russia in an apparent
planning Expedition for Kim's possible
visit
so what would a potential deal look like
Russia's after artillery and raw
materials for its military to sustain
its war in Ukraine and in exchange North
Korea may receive Russian food Aid and
Advance technology for satellite and
nuclear submarine development U.S
officials warned such a deal between
Russia and North Korea would violate U.N
security Council resolutions and has
vowed to sanction all those involved
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington
he's a research fellow at yonsei
University's Institute for North Korean
studies he joins us now from Seoul let's
start with pyongyang's weapons
production capability I've been
wondering just how much of a help they
could be to the Russians
well it depends on how desperate uh
Russia is a situation in the war with
Ukraine actually is uh the very fact
that the Putin governments and the
minister of National Defense to
Pyongyang in celebration of the day of
the Armistice agreement signed which was
in uh Late July indicates that the
Russian situation is quite desperate in
demand for additional uh War materials
like the inventory Rockets or artillery
shells provided by North Korea you
mentioned Sergey schweigu's visit there
to Pyongyang where he saw a whole load
of missiles on display how much does
North Korea need new military technology
pyongyang's obviously always trying to
show how advanced their weapons are is
this deal potentially about technology
or more about Aid
uh we have to widen our you know web of
our imagination uh the cooperation and
the coordination between Moscow and
Pyongyang may be various and ongoing but
Russia needs weapons here and now
because it has been involving one
Ukraine on the other hand North Korea
has a big ambition to develop five major
strategic weapons as announced in the
party Congress held in January 2019
including military reconnaissance
satellites and nuclear propelled
summaries we have to wait and see
whether Putin government is ready to
provide such Advanced military
Technologies to North Korea in exchange
for very conventional weapon system
because the deal is not in favor of
Russia you say that it's a wait and see
situation but when we get to heads of
state level how far along are
negotiations is this now potentially
about Sealing the deal if this meeting
does take place
um we have to wait and see if the
meeting between the two two top leaders
of the Russian North Korea will actually
take place uh potentially in Vladivostok
the very fact that the the summit
meeting is required for these countries
to finite finalize the weapon exchange
and trade means that there are a lot of
us Kings details uh to be ironed out and
agreed at the very highest level of the
governments well I know back in 2014
North Korea recognized annexed Crimea as
Russian territory right presumably then
hoping to receive some kind of economic
incentive in return but even the
Russians admit that that has not
happened they're not formal allies now
but I understand they have a cooperation
agreement of sorts from 2000 what does
that actually mean in practice
well I mean they're on the clean slate
in terms of agreeing upon exchange and
trade of weapons and food as well uh so
uh it is a very difficult negotiations
for both sides to strike a deal so uh
the most likely scenario would be Russia
providing full day to North Korea which
is uh B9 and North Korea uh continue to
be aggressive in contemplating a weapon
deal with Russia well it feels like
Beijing has really led the way in terms
of relations with Pyongyang I've been
wondering how Russia is regarded in
North Korea I understand there's been
very little coverage of the Ukraine war
and in the North Korean domestic press
right definitely and North Korea would
be very much interest in the end of the
war in Ukraine uh in that case then the
North Korea may send the laborers uh to
have opportunity to run Hard Cash uh
from the other
Ukraine area after the war is over
a research fellow at Yonce University's
Institute for North Korean studies
speaking to us from Seoul thank you so
much for sharing your insights with us
here on altazira